BUT FIRST, A WAR OF WORDS AMONG
TWO REPORTED TARGETS OF THE
MUELLER PROBE.
EARLIER TODAY, THE DAILY CALLER
REPORTED OF AN EARLY COPY OF
BOOK WRITTEN BY AUTHOR JEROME
CORSI.
IN THIS BOOK, CORSI CLAIMED THAT
HE TESTIFIED TO MUELLER'S GRAND
JURY THAT JUST ONE MONTH BEFORE
THE 2016 ELECTION, ROGER STONE,
ASKED LIMB TO CONTACT JULIAN
ASSANGE ABOUT RELEASING
PODESTA'S E-MAIL.
CORSI CLAIMS THAT WAS BECAUSE
STONE HAD ADVANCED KNOWLEDGE OF
THE RELEASE OF THOSE ACCESS
HOLLYWOOD TAPE AND ADVANCE
KNOWLEDGE OF THE E-MAILS
THEMSELVES.
CORSI WAS ASKED ABOUT THIS
EARLIER TONIGHT ON OUR OWN
TUCKER CARLSON.
>> THIS IS A POLITICAL WITCH
HUNT.
I DID NOT HAVE A CONTACT WITH
ASSANGE.
I HAVE FIGURED OUT THAT ASSANGE
HAD PODESTA'S E-MAIL.
I TOLD ROGER STONE AND TOLD MANY
PEOPLE IN AUGUST.
I DID FIGURE IT OUT AND I
CONNECTED THE DOTS.
THIS TIME I HAPPEN TO BE RIGHT.
YOU WON'T BELIEVE THAT I FIGURED
IT OUT.
>> Laura: ROGER STONE IS
DISPEWING SOME OF CORSI'S OTHER
CLAIMS AND HE HAS A LOT TO STAY.
HE JOIN US NOW IN AN EXCLUSIVE
INTERVIEW.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU TONIGHT.
I KNOW YOU WATCHED WHAT
MR. CORSI SAID ON TUCKER CARLSON
SHOW.
LOT OF FOLKS WATCHING AND THEY
THINK OF THE MUELLER PROBE.
THEY HEAR ASSANGE NAME AND THEY
DON'T KNOW WHO JEROME CORSI IS.
SIMPLIFY THIS FOR US IS OUR
LISTENERS KNOW WHAT THEY NEED
KNOW TO UNDERSTAND THE CURRENT
STATE AFFAIRS IN THIS
INVESTIGATION.
>> FIRST OF ALL, THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME.
MY OWN SHOW IS SO HEAVILY
CENSORED TO DENY ME A FORUM TO
DEFEND MYSELF.
I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE CHANCE TO
BE HERE.
THIS IS VERY SIMPLE.
QUITE CLEARLY, I MADE IT VERY
CLEAR THAT ON AUGUST 21st, I
POSTED A TWEET THAT SAID, THE
PODESTA'S TIME IN THE BARREL
WILL COME.
I MEANT THAT PUBLIC SCRUTINY OF
PODESTA'S BUSINESS INTEREST AS I
HAVE BEEN BRIEFED ABOUT WILL BE
IN THE MEDIA.
NOW JERRY CORSI HAS BEEN
BROWBEAT INTO CLAIMING THAT WAS
A COVER STORY.
BECAUSE HISTORY TAKING HEAT FOR
THAT TWEET.
THAT'S NOT EVEN LOGICAL.
MY TWEET WASN'T CONTROVERSIAL
UNTIL SIX WEEKS LATER WHEN
JULIAN ASSANGE PUBLISHED JOHN
PODESTA'S E-MAILS.
THEN THE SECONDARY CLAIM THAT I
KNEW ABOUT THE BILLY BUSH NBC
TAPE IN ADVANCE AND I ASKED
JERRY CORSI TO CONTACT JULIAN
ASSANGE TO ASK ASSANGE TO MOVE
UP OR MOVE BACK HIS DATA DUMP TO
DISTRACT THE ATTENTION FROM
THAT, THAT'S A FAIRYTALE.
I LEARNED ABOUT IT AT 4:00 IN
THE AFTERNOON LIKE EVERY OTHER
AMERICAN.
I WAS ON THE STREET IN
MANHATTAN.
>> Laura: THERE'S NO TEXT
EVIDENCE OR E-MAIL EVIDENCE
REGARDING THE BILLY BUSH CLAIM.
NOTHING DEFINITIVE ABOUT THE
OTHER CLAIM ABOUT ADVANCE
KNOWLEDGE.
THERE'S JUST ONE E-MAIL FROM YOU
TO CORSI FROM JULY 25, 2016.
THEN THIS IS FROM THE DRAFT
COURT PAPERS.
GET TO AT THE ECUADORIAN EMBASSY
AND GET THE PENDING WICK LEAKS
E-MAIL.
>> HOURS BEFORE THAT, I WAS
FORWARDED A E-MAIL BY JAMES
ROADSEN OF -- ROSEN OF FOX THAT
WAS SENT TO ME ONE OF THE BEST
RESEARCHERS IN THE COUNTRY.
ROSEN HAD GOTTEN A TIP THAT THE
DISCLOSURES WERE ABOUT THE
CLINTON FOUNDATION.
LIKE EVERY POLITICAL REPORTER IN
AMERICA I WAS CURIOUS ABOUT WHAT
ASSANGE HAD.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS IS CLEAR.
NOTHING WE LEARNED SHOWS THERE
WAS ANY COLLUSION BETWEEN THE
RUSSIAN STATE AND DONALD TRUMP'S
CAMPAIGN.
$20 MILLION AND TWO YEARS IN,
THERE'S STILL NO EVIDENCE OF ANY
SUCH RUSSIAN COLLUSION.
>> Laura: NOT ACCORDING TO DAVID
FROM TODAY ON CNN WHO MADE A
CONTRARY CLAIM
>> THIS IS EVIDENCE OF ONGOING
CONSPIRACY OR COLLUSION BETWEEN
HIGH-RANKING TRUMP CAMPAIGN
OFFICIALS AND WIKILEAKS AND
JULIAN ASSANGE AND THE STOLEN
E-MAILS.
YOU CAN SEE THAT HE'S NOT ONLY
DIRECTING JEROME CORSI TO GET
COPY OF THE E-MAILS ABOUT THEM.
HE REPORTS BACK TO ROGER STONE
ON AUGUST 2nd.
>> Laura: YOUR RESPONSE TO HIM.
>> WHEN DID POLITICAL GOSSIP
BECOME CRIMINALIZED.
EVERYONE IN THE AMERICA WANTED
TO SEE AFTER ASSANGE TEASED
E-MAILS IN JUNE WHAT IT WAS HE
HAD.
THERE'S NO FLOW OF INFORMATION
PIP RECEIVED NO E-MAILS AND I
PASSED NO E-MAILS ON TO DONALD
TRUMP OR THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
THAT'S JUST A FAIRYTALE.
LET'S FACE IT.
THE ENTIRE RUSSIAN COLLUSION
DELUSION.
IT'S MEANT TO DISTRACTS FROM THE
FACT THAT THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION THE OBAMA N.S.A.
AND OBAMA NIB USING
UNCONSTITUTIONAL FISA WANTERS TO
SPY ON DONALD TRUMP'S CAMPAIGN.
THERE'S A GREAT NEED TO DISTRACT
FROM ALL OF THOSE THINGS.
WE POINT TO DONALD TRUMP AND THE
PHONY RUSSIAN COLLUSION.
WHICH JUST DOESN'T EXIST.
>> Laura: HAVE YOU BEEN OFFERED
A DEAL BETHE SPECIAL COUNSEL?
>> MOST CERTAINLY NOT.
THERE'S NO CIRCUMSTANCE UNDER
WHAT SO EVER THAT I WILL BEAR
FALSE WITNESS AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT.
I SUPPORTED DONALD TRUMP FOR
PRESIDENT AND BECAUSE I HELPED
DEFEAT HILLARY CLINTON AND FOR